la présidente ma question s'adresse au
garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre l'accès et
l'exploitation des données de connexion
sont devenus depuis plusieurs années un
facteur majeur d'élucidation des
enquêtes pénales toutefois cette
technique denquête doit s'inscrire dans
le respect des libertés individuelles
hors la loi française parce qu'elle
permet au procureur de la république
d'accéder à ces données sans contrôle
préalable ou immédiatement ultérieure
d'une juridiction ou d'une entité
administrative indépendante est
contraire au droit de l'union cela
résulte des quatre arrêts de la cour de
cassation du 12 juillet dernier qui tire
les conséquences de décisions rendues
par la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
césar et énonce aussi que l'accès aux
données de connexion doit être justifiée
par l'objectif de prévention du
terrorisme ou de lutte contre la
criminalité grave mais qu'est ce que la
criminalité grave une loi devrait pour
le moins préciser cette notion afin de
sécuriser les procédures en cours et à
venir sur la question principale du
contrôle notre justice n'est pas en
mesure de faire face en l'état au
changement qu'induirait une mise en
conformité dans le seul département du
puy de dôme un tel contrôle
représenterait environ 5000 saisines
supplémentaires annuelles pour le
magistrat qui en seraient chargés la
conférence des procureurs de la
république s'en est inquiété auprès de
la représentation nationale
car cette situation risque d'entraver
sérieusement l'identification des
criminels et des délinquants
monsieur le ministre qu'envisagez-vous
face à cette situation la création d'une
entité administrative indépendante
dédiée au contrôle préalable ou bien
pensez vous confier ce contrôle au juge
des libertés de la détention mais dont
il faudrait alors renforcer fortement
les effectifs je vous remercie merci
beaucoup